hey guys i am just mcdonald it's the 12
/ much and you're watching games but
news first up someone you don't know
made an awful lot of money how nice for
them said someone is Activision Blizzard
CEO Bobby Kotick who snagged himself a
seven point eight five million dollar
bonus for 2013 performance as reported
by games industry this is a pretty huge
leap from his already significant 2.1
million dollar bonus from last year do
you guys reckon this is way too much or
is it justified let me know next up
those of you worried about cyberpunk
2077 being the next one to go after the
witcher 3 SNL states delay have no need
for concern CD Projekt RED CEO martin of
in ski has said that development of
cyberpunk is not really affected he said
that you'd of the title being developed
by a different team within the studio it
shouldn't see any impact the operative
word there though is perhaps shouldn't
since some 2077 developers have moved
over to the witcher to help keep the
game production rolling and last of the
mark microsoft are expecting titanfall
to be a blockbuster of a game in an
interview Microsoft marketing exec use
of Medi declined to make an actual
estimate on just how many copies of the
game would sell although he did say that
the publisher expects big things from
titanfall medi said that titanfall is
going to be a blockbuster launch for
Xbox and a really big deal for Microsoft
do you guys agree that titanfall will be
huge and II reckon it could be game of
the year leave me your thoughts either
in the comment box down below or you can
do so on my Twitter where I'm at just
McDonald that is it for all my stories
for you today but be sure to join me
again tomorrow for a stack more news